wir haben einen ganzen Tag lang gegrillt
und ich sage euch so viel es lohnt sich
das Video zu schauen wir werden alles
anders machen als ihr erwartet aber
fangen wir an mit dem Frühstück dass man
so vielleicht nicht vom Grill erwartet
Buttermilch Pancakes obendrauf skire und
gegrillte Pfirsiche ein paar Nüsse noch
dazu das wird richtig richtig lecker ich
habe das von der Zeit gesehen auf Tinker
und ich wollte es ein bisschen
adaptieren wir machen das auch so eine
health Art und Weise bzw war das der
Plan bis er mir gesagt hat lass uns
Pancakes dazu machen scheiß drauf wir
machen das Ganze ich gebe erstmal 50 g
Butter zum Schmelzen in die Mikrowelle
dann habe ich mir eine Schüssel in die
ich erstmal 250 g Mehl gebe falls ich
Frage wie wir überhaupt sind wir sind
bei Eric zu Hause wir machen Barbecue
wir wechseln auch heute einmal den Ort
denn wir haben auch einen Long Job
geplant etwas was ganz lange auf dem
Grill braucht 50 Gramm Zucker dazu
ungefähr eine Packung Backpulver und
dann können wir das ganze schon mal
verkühlen können auch Vanillezucker
reinhauen wenn ihr Bock auch ein
bisschen Vanille Aroma habt und diese
Pfirsiche sind das Herz und das Stück
das gegrillt wird wir machen aber auch
die Pancakes auf dem Grill auf der Plan
schon gleich bin gespannt wie das
funktioniert aber gegrilltes Pfirsiche
und so nach honigglasur ja man kann das
ganze
[Musik]
jetzt sind die trockenen Zutaten
kombiniert jetzt kommen die flüssigen
dazu ganz einfach 500 Gramm Buttermilch
Buttermilch macht die Pancakes so schön
fluffig übrigens der Teig funktioniert
perfekt auch für Waffeln die
geschmolzene Butter und zwei Eier ihr
werdet merken es ist unfassbar einfach
ein geiles schnelles Frühstück ist auch
auf dem Grill zu Zauber das ganze
verrühren wir und fertig ist unser
pancaketeig kommen wir zum Star der Show
zu unseren Pfirsichen zu meiner Schande
es sich viel zu wenig Obst das kommt so
aus meiner Schulzeit wo ich das einfach
so gehasst habe wenn meine Mutter mir so
Obst mitgegeben hat aber immer wieder
wenn ich tue denke ich mir boah das ist
ja irgendwie geil schneiden
die nicht mehr Hase läuft ich habe jetzt
hier die Pfirsiche auf dem Rost
platziert die einmal schön an was macht
das das macht sie warm das macht sie
weich und das karamellisiert sie so ein
bisschen wir gehen natürlich noch ein
bisschen Honig drüber später das wird
richtig geil wenn wir einzeln unsere
Pfirsiche ein bisschen Farbe dran
Geschmack ein bisschen Honig an die
Pfirsiche
verkleben uns damit auch schön den Rost
also sind wir auch heute bei Eric das
geht auch relativ schnell ich probiere
mal hier unser Ergebnis
krass ich schwöre das boostet einen
Pfirsichgeschmack total die natürliche
Süße die durch den Honig unterstützt
wird aber mit ein bisschen Honig dran
den wir Butter auf die planscher
jetzt Achtung nehme ich hier ein paar
von meinen Kern und röste die einfach
hier hinten auf der planscher auch ein
bisschen so machen wir das nämlich ne
ein Ort nur der Grill keine Töpfe keine
Pfannen deshalb grillen wir haben einen
wunderschönen fluffigen saftigen Pancake
gegrillten für sich geröstete Kerne es
fehlt uns noch das Topping das nehme ich
mir jetzt was ihr wollt ne also nimmt
einen Vanille Joghurt wenn ihr gerade
nicht irgendwie im Fitness Film seid
Wasser unterrühren jetzt einfach und ich
was in die Mitte geben für den
ausstreichen muss das jetzt probieren es
sieht so verdammt gut aus alter was
haben wir gemacht die mich immer den
perfekten Bike hier für sich und ein
paar Körner drauf
real sogar leicht zu fluffig so soll man
nicht probiert davon kann man nicht
genug bekommen sowas kann man grillen
kann
oder ja sonst kann man sich auch eine
Größe also eine Pfanne einstellen aber
der Grill so geil so schnell so einfach
kann Frühstück sein und Küche ist sauber
mit oder ohne macht das nach geiles
Frühstück abwechslungsreich wir sehen
uns beim Mittagessen
ach Kinder schön dass Ihr da seid ich
habe mir mal eine kleine Pause gegönnt
wir sind auf Holzkohle umgestiegen sind
bei Pino und Margarita zu Gast haben
eine wunderschöne speiseform es gibt
nicht nur vagio sondern es gibt schöne
Beilagen dafür nehme ich mir erstmal ein
bisschen Petersilie habt ihr einen
ordentlichen bunt Petersilie mir gekauft
sind Chili Chili einfach geil das nicht
kennt so ein super frischer Steak Depp
Olivenöl Petersilie Chili Knoblauch that
Pfeffer natürlich noch aber so frisch so
dann nehmen wir jetzt unsere Petersilie
einmal rein fühl ich mir hier dann auch
der Blocksberg an der Stelle und ich
Filter auch noch halt nicht mehr eine
grün und eine rot ab unsere Peters
benötigen wir ein bisschen Olivenöl und
bisschen mehr brauchen
noch schneiden Olivenöl und zwar jede
Menge das ist das was uns die
soßenhaftigkeit
es gibt so eine frische eine Komponente
die man halt eigentlich gar nicht kennt
so vom Grillen
[Musik]
fertig ist unser weiter geht's mit einem
anderen dazu mache ich eine Grillpfanne
aus all diesen Gemüse jetzt Paprika
Zwiebeln Kartoffeln Aubergine so
spezielle Schlangen Auberginen sind das
hier was schnibbelig alles und dann
sieht es so aus wir geben noch ein
bisschen Olivenöl oben drüber und guckt
euch dieses Farbspiel an know Joke
richtig richtig hübsch gespannt wie das
gleich aus dem Ofen wollte ich gerade
sagen aus dem Grill kommt natürlich ein
bisschen Salz geben das einmal oben
drüber bisschen Pfeffer noch dazu Leute
das wird köstliche natürlich ist das
hier nur unser Leben Charakter der der
Hauptcharakter das vagio das kommt
gleich ins Spiel gehen wir das einmal
auf den Grill ich habe das Gemüse
platziert auf dem Rost jetzt gebe ich
den Deckel drauf hier drüben Luft zuvor
auf so dass quasi von der heißen Stelle
über das Gemüse hinweg die Luft
rauszieht das ganze wird ungefähr eine
halbe Stunde benötigen bei ständiger
Beobachtung und Bewegung los geht's so
sieht unser Gemüse jetzt aus jetzt
finishen wir das mit ein wenig
geriebenen Parmesan einfach oben drüber
gibt uns diese schönen Käse Geschmack
umami nee dann ist auch Zeit hier haben
wir unser Steak einmal pikania einmal
bei wett und wir Salzen das Ganze einmal
guckt euch das an das ist richtig
richtig schön marmoriert ich glaube das
wird richtig lecker gab es bei uns bei
Mara Atlantico so gerne einkaufen gehen
einfach mal großzügig mit Salz dran von
allen Seiten viel mehr brauchen wir
nicht wir machen auch keinen
Knoblauchpulver oder irgendwas einfach
einmal schön auf
das auch auf und schauen einmal machen
wir boah wirklich eine
bilderbuchkruste das sieht ja richtig
perfekt aus ne lassen beide einfach noch
ein bisschen grillen und dann sehen wir
uns wenn wir probieren nehmen wir uns
unsere pikania wir haben noch ein
bisschen geruht schneiden das gute Stück
an
guckt euch das einfach mal an man sieht
richtig schön dieses Pferd
sehr sehr intensiver Geschmack einfach
mal so ein bisschen von der Chemie
einmal oben drauf
boah das ist so saftig unser Grillgemüse
wenn jetzt die Kartoffeln 10 Minuten
früher drauf weil ich einfach ein
bisschen länger braucht und jetzt einmal
das bleib Steak ihr seht perfekt die
Fasern wir schneiden natürlich gegen die
Faser saftig und man spürt wirklich auf
der oberflächlich ist so eine richtig
schöne also
ich würde sagen ein bisschen alt
aussehen
wenn man hübschen Teller Anzeigen
vielleicht auch nicht weiß jemand auch
jetzt zum Abendessen wieder bzw zu den
Vorbereitungen fürs Abendessen Freunde
es wird ernst ich habe zwar gerade schon
das Mittagessen gesehen wir befinden uns
jetzt gerade aber davor denn wir haben
einen Job vor das habe ich vorhin schon
erwähnt hier kümmern uns unsere
liegen zwei Stück an der Zahl
wunderschön haben wir uns schon die
Membran entfernt wir wollen nicht zu
tief in die barbecue
Materie einsteigen tut mir ein bisschen
Olivenöl gebt die Babys einmal hier
hinein bisschen Öl drüber damit unser
RUB gleich besser anhaftet echt zu sein
das war vom Mann hinter der Kamera der
Traum was wir hier gerade machen
als wir uns kennengelernt haben hat Erik
schon die ganze Zeit davon gesprochen so
long Job auf dem Smoker whatever eric
ist auf jeden Fall sehr Grill
passioniert genau diesen Job erledigen
wir jetzt unser RUB ist ein Mischmasch
aus verschiedenen Sachen die wir
rumfliegen hat irgendwie so ein Bier
gewürzt dann Magic das Drop Haut da rein
was ihr wollt wichtig ist das von allen
Seiten genug dran ist und das machen wir
jetzt wir nehmen uns unsere
150 Grad Deckel Temperatur zwei bis drei
Stunden das heißt wir gehen trainieren
mach das Mittagessen und dann geht's
weiter mittlerweile sind drei Stunden
vergangen und das ist was wir im Grill
haben das ist richtig geil und das ist
noch nicht alles denn die geben sie raus
stellen sie hier in unsere Schale hinein
mit dem Rost und jetzt sind die
Dampfphase dafür gehen wir einmal rein
und wir dämpfen das ganze nicht mit
Wasser
immer ein bisschen Geschmack deshalb
geben wir anderthalb Liter Apfelsaft
einfach unten in die Schale hinein
diesen ganzen Apparat müssen wir jetzt
einmal dicht in Alufolie einwickeln ich
habe hier extra große Alufolie das kann
man auch mit Wutscher paper machen
wichtig ist dass es schön verschlossen
ist und so kommt das ganze auf den Grill
gleiche Temperatur für weitere 2 Stunden
so Freunde weitere 2 Stunden später wir
waren zwischenzeitlich im Gym wir haben
das uns jetzt verdient dass hier drunter
schlummert hoffentlich ist es auch gut
Mama mir kommt wir gehen einmal rein und
gucken was uns der Weihnachtsmann da
unter dem Baum gelegt hat mich bisschen
Flüssigkeit ist auf jeden Fall noch drin
merke ich dass es da drin rumschwappt
und jetzt
Alter mit der ganzen Alkohol können wir
uns gegen Gedankenkontrolle werden
das hat perfekt funktioniert natürlich
schmeißen wir diesen ganzen Fleisch und
Apfelsaft nicht einfach weg sondern
bewahren ihn auf und unsere short Ribs
müssen wir jetzt gleichen das heißt
bestreichen und allen Seiten mit
Barbecue Sauce als Beilage machen wir
eine Trüffel rahmpolenta und grünen
Spargel Milch und Sahne bringe ich jetzt
erstmal auf dem Grill zum Kochen 30 40
Minuten sollte es fertig sein Mädchen
Sahne sind aufgekocht ich war immer
durch jetzt gebe ich hier die Polenta
dazu rühre die einfach ein wird mit
Muskatnuss Salz Pfeffer
also ready jetzt ist Zeit gegeben hurens
Finale den grünen Spargel dazu wenn der
angegrillt ist richten wir an hier sind
wir also ein Tag am Grill geht zu Ende
und das hier ist das Hauptprodukt
wunderschöne Shorts und wir gucken jetzt
mal ob sie den knochentest bestehen
einfach so abziehen bisschen was bleibt
dran hängen das können wir glaube ich
einfach mit der Gabel lösen und was
sehen wir hier schon eine schöne Farbe
Saftigkeit die Knochen lassen sich wow
sehr schön entfernen so sehe ich das
immer auf Instagram und wir haben es
einfach selbst geschafft jetzt einmal
ein klassischer mittelschnitt wenn das
den knochentest den zweiten Knochen Test
besteht dann haben wir es richtig
gemacht
Alter wir können es wirklich aber mit
dem Knochen schneiden so zart ist es
wenn wir ein bisschen was von meiner
fakey und platziere das hier einmal über
meinem Gericht gegrillter Spargel
Trüffel Rahm Polenta und beef Shorts
Leute probieren wir das Ganze
mein erster Gedanke ist Gulasch weil das
auch so zerfällt im und so weiß wie so
ein richtig geiler Gulasch der so
perfekt soft gekocht ist ich nehme ein
bisschen von der rampolinter dazu
[Musik]
wirklich brutal Alter
wie schnell die ging auch so lecker
genauso wie bei dem Pancakes ich glaube
das ist mindestens so eine geile
Erkenntnis wie die Rezepte oder die
Sachen die wir heute gemacht haben das
hier zeigt dass man wirklich alles auf
dem Grill machen kann es gibt keinen
cheat codes wir haben heute gegessen das
vergleicht sich gar nicht mit dieses
Fleisch das über Zeit erst zart wird das
hat so eine eigene Charakteristik da
kann jedes noch so edles Stück sich
nicht zu vergleichen sowas weißt du
richtig lecker und das Ding ist es hat
lange gedauert wir mussten jetzt heute
immer wieder hin und her aber an für
sich wenn man am Sonntag zu Hause ist
macht das nach also ihr braucht einfach
nur Zeit um einen Plan dann läuft das
ist jetzt nicht so wie beefanten wo man
die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Sachen haben
muss wenn man chillt einfach deshalb
wenn es nach macht viel Spaß danke fürs
zuschauen schreibt in die Kommentare
wenn wir wieder mal ein Tag Grillen
sollen bis zum nächsten Mal ciao